how many previous actual Partners is too
many we did this study in 2018 I think
we basically said for a long-term
partner here's a person they're
generally attractive how willing would
you be to go on a date with them or
entertain them as a long-term partner
based on what people now call Body Count
when we did the research was just having
sexual partners they've had and it
basically Peaks at around about four
being like the optimal what's really
really cool is it's not just a linear
pattern so it's not like three to four
and then it just goes downhill you get
this little curve so people are a bit
wary about a virgin as well being a
virgin is I think equivalent to
something like having 12 Partners oh no
it's less than that it's seven to eight
Partners is the equivalent of kind of
being a virgin is this male to female
female to male is there a difference
here it depends on actual strategy